- Dude, I love confident,
white dude dancers.
- [Big Jay] It's great.
(electric guitar chords)
(fire crackling)
- I saw a video the other day,
I wish I could find the
original one I found,
because on YouTube I
can't seem to find it.
But it was just a video of a girl doing
the most spastic, weird,
fun, sort of, but like,
dancing.
And it said EDM Shuffle Dance Girl.
- EDM Shuffle Dance Girl?
- Yeah, and that's what I remember,
just like the key words to remember.
I can't find the original
one I saw on Facebook,
but then I just looked it up
on YouTube and watched it.
It's, I guess,
high-on-molly EDM dancing.
- Is this the girl?
- No, no.
- [Dan] Who's she though?
- [Big Jay] Another one doing it.
I'm telling you.
- Top five shuffle vines.
- I didn't even know this was
a whole culture of EDM shuffling,
if you're aware of this at all.
- Whoa.
- [Big Jay] It pretty much
starts at the running man.
Running man's a lot of it.
- They're just moving their feet.
They have glowed-up feet.
- Well, you don't have to,
although Black Lou says he
does own a pair of these.
- Black Lou, do you know
how to dance like this?
- [Black Lou] Not at all.
- Not at all?
- Not at all.
- Look at this.
- You're about to.
- [Christine] It looks like Crip walking.
- [Dan] You're a Crip walk.
- You're a Crip walk.
- It does.
- You are a Crip walk.
- [Dan] Whatever.
We have to get these shoes.
- Well, Christine, so you're
saying you have a leg up
because you know how to Crip walk?
- [Christine] I don't know
how to do any of that.
- Can we--
- I don't like these,
these are too good.
These are making me upset
like we shouldn't try,
although I still want to.
- Or it actually looks like
Blood walk.
- I think we need these shoes.
- You don't.
- All I'm seeing is
we need shoes.
- [Big Jay] You don't
need the shoes at all,
that's just the...
- [Dan] This kid's awesome.
Looks like he was just--
- These people
are too good at it.
I wanna see the ones that are all whacked.
- Yeah, do bad.
Because this is hard to watch,
because it's like, I can't do that.
Nah dude, look at her butt.
- Dan, Dan, look at me.
You can do it.
- [Dan] Yeah?
- You just can!
- Or if I see someone
bad do it.
- There's no way to do it wrong!
- Oh my God, they're doing choreographed?
- These are vines, this
isn't what we should've,
this is people showing
off, fuckin' swingin' dick.
I wanna see idiots at home do it.
- (laughs) Sick soldier stomping.
- There we go, that guy.
- [Christine] It's like Riverdance.
- [Big Jay] Yes, it's a
little bit Riverdance,
it's a lot of running man.
- It's like Lord of the Dance
with Michael Flatley.
- Now we're cookin' with gas.
- (laughs) It's a lot of Running Man.
- Yeah dude, I just wanna
see bad versions of this.
- Here we go, Shuffle Fail Compilation.
- Beau-ti-ful.
Blast it!
Shuffle fail!
Yeah, this is me.
- This is what might happen in the studio.
(electronic dance music)
- [Dan] Yeah.
- Is he doing that bad?
- [Dan] I don't think it's good.
(Christine laughs)
- You don't?
- [Dan] I think he hits that main carpet,
he's gonna be in some trouble.
At the Bonfire SXM.
- Oh, he's about to catch a lip.
- Oh, he's steppin', steppin',
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
How's this a fail?
Oh!
And he hit it.
That's awesome.
- He busted the thing, so
there's a bunch of fails.
- [Dan] Oh, you can do
the horse? (clicks tongue)
- Yeah, but you can do whatever you want,
as long as your legs are just
goin' fuckin' flippy-floppy nonstop
from the second you
start 'til you're done.
- I think I wanna do the happy prospector.
- [Big Jay] Keep your hand work,
your hand work's gotta be minimal.
- Oh so it's like, bum,
bum, bum, bum, like that?
Oh, this is Riverdance.
♪ I think it's very vital ♪
- It's the same thing.
- Christine, stop confusing
the situation, stay with shuffle dancing.
- Oh yeah, this is me.
- There you go, that's
gonna be you, I agree.
You're assuming yours will
be something like that.
And some way you're gonna think
you did a complete straddle split.
(Dan and Big Jay groan)
- [Dan] Yeah, that's me.
(all groan)
(Big Jay laughs)
- It's just a guy falling on
his back and staying there.
Here we go.
Whenever you try it
outside of a school ground,
you know you're destined to fuck up.
Oh, I could do this.
- [Big Jay] Yeah, this is
how I feel it's gonna go.
Whoa, what?
Hey!
(Dan laughs)
- [Dan] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Must learn balance
before you shuffle dance.
- This is great because it's slick fours.
He's in trouble.
- [Big Jay] He's got a whole lot
of electronics.
- That whole
entertainment center's going
down, at the Bonfire SXM.
We'll tweet it out he just, eh? (groans)
- Oh, come on.
That's in a fail compilation,
you don't fail at this a lot.
- Hey could we go out to the parking lot
so you can film me doing
some shuffle dancing?
- This is like he's fighting wind.
- It's actually pretty awesome.
Is this the reporter stuck in a hurricane?
(Big Jay laughs)
Hm, hm, hm, hm.
Oh man, I think we could all do this.
- Nobody in this room gets outta here
without shuffle dancing.
(DJ Lou laughs)
- Dude, I'll go first.
You think I'm scared?
This song, I wanna dance to this song.
- [DJ Lou] I think I have it.
- I don't know what this--
- This girl's doing it
with her, it looks so fun.
It looks like you're doing nothing.
- And you gotta take your shoes off.
- It looks like something
you get caught doing
in an elevator and have to stop.
- After you get promoted?
(Big Jay and Dan laugh)
- [Big Jay] Beep beep bop,
somebody's gonna buy an Alfa Romeo!
Hey, hey.
- Hey, sorry.
- [Big Jay] What's up,
thought this was going
straight down to the lobby.
- I just got the Johnson deal.
(Big Jay and Dan laugh)
Cha, cha, cha, cha, cha.
Do we know what songs these are?
Hey.
Hi.
Oh, this is terrible.
Actually that's not bad.
- Lot of these girls in there
have been fart porn. (laughs)
(Dan makes farting noises)
Little-known fact.
All these girls in there
have been fart porn.
(farting)
(Dan laughs)
Oh, Jesus H.
- All right, are we gonna
pick out some music?
I get it, it's sock dancing, I got it.
- [DJ Lou] I pulled
some songs for you guys.
- It's North American sock dancing.
- You don't have to be in socks though.
- Guess who's gonna be in socks.
- Are you going to socks?
- Yeah, dude.
- Maybe I should go to socks too.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- For sure socks.
- Watch out.
- I bet I'd break a big toe
by just kicking the ground really hard
when I'm just flailing
my feet like a doof.
I'm just gonna crank my foot.
- I can't wait to have an ankle brace.
- Troy from Philadelphia just said,
we don't have to take the
call, but thanks for the call.
Troy goes, he goes, "I go to EDC events
"and you won't see anyone,"
he's saying you won't see
anybody fucked up doing that.
Yeah, you can't.
If you're fucked up, you're
going over right away.
They won't even know you
were trying to do that,
they'll go, "Looks like Dan
can't get his legs under him,
"oh, he's down, he's down." (laughs)
Everyone there will be
like, "He can't get his legs
"under him, oh, oh, he's doing the dance."
As soon as you look like you don't have
your legs under you, you don't.
- Who's gonna start this off?
- [Big Jay] DJ Lou.
- I'm the DJ.
- [Big Jay] All right, it can't be DJ Lou,
it's gotta be one of, I'd say...
- I'll try.
- Jacob's gonna be a great one.
You wanna go first?
You can go first if you wanna go first.
- Because I think I'll be terrible at it.
- We're all gonna be sorta terrible at it.
- Yeah, but I'll start.
- But put your heart into it.
- You can't move your hands?
- No, you can.
Look at these people moving their hands,
but just it's mostly, it's
a foot-based situation.
You're gonna do it over here?
- Yeah.
- We'll swap spots.
- All right.
- [Big Jay] You have to use my headphones.
- Everyone dancing has
to use my headphones.
We got this.
Jacob, play me out. (laughs)
- I'm ready, I'm ready, I got it.
Jacob, come on, what are you doing?
Also, we gotta bring the mic up.
- [Big Jay] Jacob, are you...
- [Jacob] The way you said it
I thought that you were talking
to like square dancing, line dancing.
- Oh, look who's getting nervous now.
"Well, let me know
"when it's square
dancing day," says Jacob.
- Oh no, no, you know
me, I'm a country fella.
I'm an urban cowboy.
- Oh, I came in prepared to boot scoot,
if I would've known I
would've trained for this.
- Let's try this shit out.
- I like it over here.
- Are you ready?
- It's kinda weird, right?
- I like it.
- Wait, let me see this again.
Let me watch a video.
- Are you in socks?
- Yeah.
- Wait get those--
- I kinda know how to do it.
- No, don't stare, that's what I'm saying,
you don't overthink it.
Just go fuckin' haywire
with your feet, man.
- Okay, all right.
- Oh shit, sorry.
- [Big Jay] Get the chairs outta the way.
We need both those chairs outta the way.
Put one in the hallway if we got to.
- No, we're good.
- I want that one gone.
That's space.
That's prime real estate right there.
- [DJ Lou] Do you want my
special sunglasses, Dan?
- Yeah, thank you.
- That'll help.
- I'd be careful,
make sure you don't kick the console
and then break your toe.
- All right, start it off
again so I can get into it.
- Danny Soder.
Let the beat drop. (laughs)
(all laughing)
- This is fuckin' ridiculous!
- Try to have some style with it,
you're really clunkin' around.
I mean, you know, where's your grace?
- I'm the first one out!
- That's fair enough, it's true.
- I don't know what I'm doing.
- It looks like you're
getting ready for two-a-days.
- (laughs) I'm just doing
an old football drill.
- Are you gonna hit the deck?
- I tried, that was
me, that was me trying.
- That wasn't bad.
It was not good.
- No, it wasn't good,
but I'll tell you this,
those old football drills
really came in handy.
(Big Jay laughs)
- It was from your heart. (laughs)
- Did you film that, Lou?
- He's got my butt.
- Black Lou, you got it?
- I mean, we got two cameras on it.
- Should me and you
bookend it, or should I go?
- Yeah, you go last, because
you're gonna be good at it.
So why don't you--
- Why would you believe that?
- Why don't I move to that mic.
- Why don't you come back to your mic,
and I'll go right here.
- I mean, yeah.
- I gotta talk while you come around,
Jacob just panics and doesn't say a word.
(Dan laughs)
Holy shit.
- It's like Major League
II, where he's like,
"It's hit, it's caught."
Hey, it's the Jake, it's Jake the Snake.
- Don't like this.
- Yeah, so I'm not good at this dancing,
but hey, at least I felt it out.
- Why would you say that?
No, don't play it up so
negative, you did good.
I was really proud of you.
- I didn't do good.
- I was really proud of you back there.
So who goes next then?
- I don't know, who wants to go next?
- Black Lou?
- I'll go.
- What?
- Jacob!
- And I'm gonna
crush this, too.
- [Dan] You're gonna what?
- I'm gonna have to school you.
(all laughing)
- Am I about to get served by Jacob?
Oh man, I really hope.
- I love it.
- I'll tell you this,
if you don't school me you're terrible.
Oh!
- Oh, motherfucker.
- [Dan] One of his multiple
layers is coming off.
- I gotta take the shoes off.
- [Dan] Yeah, you gotta go socks.
- [Big Jay] Oh yeah, I
gotta go shoes off too, huh?
- Yeah guys, if you guys are gonna fuckin'
EDM shuffle dance.
- If you guys are ready to get
your heads outta your asses.
- If you guys wanna take
this thing seriously,
like what it is?
Which is a real, live, radio
show, that is doing some dumb.
- Came in smelling like onion,
left it smelling like feet.
- Hey Lou, drop a beat for me.
[All] Oh!
- Straight street!
(all laughing)
- Yeah, Jacob is schooling me!
Look at the feet moving, oh!
- Owning it!
- He's not stopping, he's not stopping!
He is not stopping.
He can't be beat, oh, oh, oh,
he likes the arms behind
the back, there it is.
Push it, push it.
Push it.
- I want everybody to remember this,
we're competing for the Golden Ring Pop.
- Oh, oh, oh, double, double back-push!
- Shuffle dancing's premiere!
- He's outlasted me.
Jacob is, oh, oh, oh, he's still moving!
Is he on ice?
There he is.
- That good enough?
- I love it.
(Dan claps)
Love it!
There's no time limit,
you can feel until your
heart stops telling you.
- Yeah, I did five seconds,
you just Luke Perry'd it,
you just eight-seconds'd it.
- [Jacob] Whatever.
(all laughing)
You good to go again?
- Christine's gonna take over
filming when Lou dances.
- Yeah, Black Lou, are you
about to jump in next, or White Lou?
Which one of the Lous is next?
- [Man] White Lou!
- [DJ Lou] I don't know.
- Come on.
- I don't know.
No one's ever said that
before shuffle dancing.
- Black Lou!
- Ah, Christ.
He goes, "Hey, you
wanna go shuffle dance?"
He goes, "God, gotta get
outta my goddamn chair."
- He's just, "Golly."
(Big Jay sighs)
Miserable sons of bitches.
- Chest is killing me.
- Are you going?
- Christine, you're next?
- [Christine] Is it me?
- Sure.
- Yeah, you gotta go.
You gotta go, Christine,
we all have to do it.
We all have to jump off.
- Look at her
rolling her eyes, she's like,
"God, let me, all right, fine.
"Finally somebody who
knows what's going on."
- Yeah, let's see.
I mean, Jacob's a hard act to follow.
I set the bar low, then
Jacob just slam-dunked it.
- Christine, you're gonna
look like Joey Lawrence
doing this dance with your fuckin' shirt
tied around your waist.
- Whoa, whoa!
- [DJ Lou] Ready?
- Here it is.
Yeah!
Go Christine, doing it!
Kick out, kick out,
she's got one good move.
She's got one solid move.
- She's really going back
to that well, everyone.
(all laughing)
Soon as that beat changes,
she's gonna lose her shit.
- There it is!
- Now looks like she
stopped giving a shit,
and she's out.
- And she's out.
And she's out, right now Jacob's in first,
Christine's in second and I am leading,
not leading, I'm following up.
- If that was a mechanical bull contest
you wouldn't have gotten laid
from the fattest guy
at that bar with that,
the way you quit.
That was great, everyone's digging in.
- Christine started off strong.
- She knew that move.
That move she was onboard with.
- That move was in.
She was in that move.
- But then they were like,
"Hey, whatever happens if it gets past,
"I don't know, seven
seconds of that move?"
And she was like, "I did
not think that far ahead."
- It's like holding
Tyson to past six rounds.
You're like, "He's gonna gas,
"he's gonna gas, just hold it in."
- I wanna get good at it.
- Black Lou or White Lou?
- White Lou.
- White Lou first?
- I don't think I'm going, I gotta DJ.
- Oh, you're going.
- Oh, come the fuck on.
- Jacob, can you run the board?
- [Jacob] Can I?
(all laughing)
Lou, can you hit my intro?
- Yeah, hell yeah!
- If you could please
hit the intro for Jacob.
- Double down.
- [Announcer] DJ Jacob.
D-D-DJ Jacob.
Spinnin' the hits.
(siren blares)
- Black Lou, we gotta make you an intro
so we can sub you in too.
- Okay.
- But we gotta
make it fuckin', we have
to make it like, black.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh man--
- Snow, Snow.
- Don't even, guys, shut up.
That's tomorrow's episode.
- I forgot, I forgot, I know.
- You guys keep talking
about tomorrow's episode.
All right, you ready White Lou?
- [DJ Lou] Fuck yeah.
- So ready to get it on,
he's already dancing.
The music hasn't even started
and he wants to get it over with so bad.
- Make it loud, Jacob.
I don't know, I got nothing.
- No!
- No, you fuckin'!
(all laughing)
- I got nothing.
(Big Jay laughing)
Now I'm all embarrassed, I'm out.
- He goes, he goes, huh.
- Lou, you get back there, Lou!
No, Lou!
Lou, no!
No, Lou, no! (laughs)
- No!
- Lou made one move and fuckin' bailed.
- Lou went, and it wasn't even feet.
He went...
- You guys were dying
laughing so hard.
- He didn't even do his feet!
Lou just went, he went, "All
right, I don't wanna do it."
(all laughing)
- It was one move!
He went, "Now I'm done, I'm done."
- He just did like a
little over-the-shoulder,
he went, he goes, boom-do-do, and he went,
"Guys, this is stupid."
Lou, you can't quit that quick!
- [Jacob] I really thought
he was gonna Chris Penn this.
And just kill it.
And then, no.
- Everyone thought
you were gonna kill it.
- It didn't happen
at all like that.
- Holy shit, that was funny.
- Oh, God dammit, that really rattled
those horseradish chips in my stomach.
- Why won't you try, Lou?
- I just had all the
confidence drained out of me.
(Dan laughs)
- You did it yourself, though!
No one said anything!
- Maybe if you guys weren't
laughing in my face,
I think I could continue.
- We're not laughing!
- We laughed after!
- You did one move!
- You, just wait--
- We didn't even laugh at your dancing!
- We can't laugh at your
dancing, you never danced!
- We laughed at you bailing on dancing.
- You threw your arms like you were
about to start the flamenco. (laughs)
And then you took off.
- [Jacob] I bet if Pete and Sebastian
asked you to dance you'd do it.
- Oh, he's right!
He's right, oh, what happened?
- [Jacob] You need us
to call them up?
- You jerks EDM dancing
last night?
- There's no time for dancing,
we're too busy laughing.
- Lou, you gotta get out
there and you have to dance.
- Lou, aren't you embarrassed--
- That you made one move,
- Oh my God, dude.
- And then just disintegrated
into nothing?
- That was one of my favorite
things I've ever seen my life.
(Dan laughing)
And my fuckin' cheeks hurt.
- Lou, we were not
laughing at your dancing,
we laughed at you bailing on the dancing.
- Immediately!
- Immediately.
Immediately.
- Confidence comes and
goes, what can I tell ya?
- No shit!
I mean, fleeting as
anything I've ever seen!
- That's the equivalent
of going like this.
It's raining, no it's not,
that was just a drip from the sky.
- He goes, "Nope, air conditioner."
- Yeah.
- Should we do a Stew day
and have him dance as Stew?
- Yes, yes.
- Yes, I mean
who dances sober?
- These people.
- Apparently everybody,
if not, you're going through a hedge, man.
I don't know if you've
seen what's going on,
it's violent feet movement.
- Black Lou, are you ready?
You're not ready.
Yeah, you're ready,
you were born ready.
- Born ready.
- Jinx.
Let's kiss.
You still gotta go, big daddy.
- Yeah, I thought we were bookending it,
I'm after Black Lou.
- I'm so glad I'm done.
It's like going on stage.
Right Lou?
How good does it feel to be done?
- You got it out of the way.
- I didn't even start.
- Isn't it nice to be done, Lou?
(DJ Lou laughs)
- Dude, that was so great.
- All right, Black Lou's coming in.
- Yeah, coming in hot.
Cowboy hat on.
- I'm told they have
softer bones for more rhythmic moving.
- Oh, here he goes.
Uh-oh!
Here it is.
Shoes on, side to side!
Jacob, you got some competition, dude.
- [Jacob] I'm not really
seeing the footwork.
- Well, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, and
Black Lou's already,
he's gaining on him, there it is.
Yeah, lotta hand.
- I'll tell you what,
the hand stuff's working.
- He does, and he's doing a lotta tilt,
I'm noticing the tilt.
- Glow stick ready!
- Yeah, oh, oh, oh!
- Oh, he almost did the Russian thing!
- I mean, it's definitely
between Black Lou and Jacob.
It's definitely between
Black Lou and Jacob.
- [Jacob] Gonna have to do a dance-off.
- You guys might have to get,
dude, someone's about to served.
- [Jacob] It's gonna get street.
- It's gonna get--
- It's about to get straight hood in here.
- You know how I like it.
Suburb.
- You know how I like
it, the berm of the hood.
- Yeah.
- You know, like the outskirts,
like where you still
get affordable places,
but it's like, nicer Hispanic families.
- Young parents.
- You know how I keep it, young parents.
- Straight street, all right.
- You ready?
You ready to do this?
This is the last one, and
then I think it's gonna come,
great job Black Lou.
I think it's gonna come
down to Jacob and Black Lou
if Jay cannot--
- Oh, thanks for counting me out.
- Dude, I don't know what you do,
I was just very impressed
with Black Lou moving.
- I gotta empty my pockets,
I wanna be light on my feet.
- You're gonna take out your chain?
- No.
- Oh, you're gonna keep
the chain for movement?
- Chain stays.
- Oh dude, I really like
where this is going.
- [Black Lou] Two chain!
- I think I need some
chairs outta the way.
- Yeah, you gotta worry about,
we got a laptop right there.
- That's fine, that'll be fine.
- You good enough?
You feel like you got space?
- [DJ Lou] Jay, if you're
not feeling the song,
just tell me to change it and I will.
- Is it the No Doubt one again?
- No.
- That stunk.
- [DJ Lou] Yeah, I knew
you didn't like that.
Yeah, oh, oh! (laughs)
Okay!
Walking forward, walking sideways!
You're doing a lot of
cartoon shuffling here.
You're going around, I like the flare-out.
Flare it, flare it, move it, flare it,
move it, flare it, side to side, side--
(all shouting)
You definitely won.
You definitely, out of the
two of us, you won that one.
- Of me and you?
- Yeah, of me and you.
- I feel like my face look
frightened the whole time.
- It did.
(all laughing)
You looked like you were walking--
- I'm going through a window.
I'm gonna go through a window!
- I felt like I was trying to talk you
over a tightrope walk.
I was like, "Come on, come on."
- Were my out-kicks good?
- Your out-kicks were great.
That was your Christine move.
(Big Jay laughs)
Your out-kicks were--
- The out-kick, I did go
back to the well a lot.
- Yeah, you did, you
were doing the out-kick,
but by the way, I was
just doing foot shuffle,
I went back to the well
the whole time too.
It's definitely Black Lou and Jacob
are the two best EDM shuffle dancers.
- I feel like you need slipperier surface.
- Yeah, I think you get
hurt that way though.
You're gonna blow the knee out.
I mean, do we wanna keep
this You Got Served style
between Black Lou and Jacob?
- Absolutely.
- [Dan] Black Lou, are you ready?
- [Black Lou] Sure.
- [Dan] Are you ready to
keep it, ready to keep it,
straight grimy?
- Straight street?
- You know how I like it.
- Grimy.
- Straight street.
- You know how I like it.
Unregulated.
- Jacob's going first right?
- I shouldn't be this out of breath.
- I'm out of breath, I'm worried
I'm having a heart attack
because I ate horseradish chips
and then danced real quick.
That's how unhealthy I am.
- No, Jacob, these headphones.
- Yeah, you can't take
your own headphones, dude.
What are you doing?
- Well you know
he doesn't like wearing
other people's headphones.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
So Jacob will be going first.
- My ears have been AIDS-free
for three years.
- Jacob's the white dance crew.
So Black Lou, let me give you my advice.
Take it how we always
do it, straight serious.
Sirius XM.
You ready, Jacob?
- Straighten your new
tee neck, your tee neck.
- I'm just waiting for the beat.
(Dan and Big Jay laugh)
(electronic dance music)
(Black Lou laughs)
- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
- Damn.
Damn!
- Oh, he's moving!
- He goes for it!
- I mean, feet just a-flailin'.
- [Man] Holy shit!
- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, Sierra Skye, if she's right now,
she's interested in Jacob.
He does a good push.
- I'll tell you, wherever
she's at, she's--
(Dan shouts)
- Oh, he just threw
some shade at Black Lou!
- Wherever Sierra Skye is,
she's wet and she doesn't even know why.
- Yeah, she's just like going somewhere
and she's, "Roman, I think it's over.
"I think it's over."
I mean, you threw a lot
of shade at him, dude.
- [Jacob] Thank you.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- Jay, what did you think--
- Thank you.
About Jacob's performance?
- Fantastic.
- It was fantastic.
Black Lou.
- He's got a lot to live up to.
- You really set the bar, dude.
You really set the bar,
but I feel like Black Lou's
got something in his pocket,
because he just gave White Lou--
- I didn't like my performance.
I'm going back and I'm
just, I'm in my own head.
- Dude, you know what, man?
- No.
- We're learning
this world together, hey, look at me.
- It was just--
- Hey, look at me.
We're learning this world together, dude.
- There was a chair to my, I was--
- That's how I felt,
hey, that's how I felt.
But you know what?
We all learned that...
Well, we all suck at this, except Jacob--
- I don't give a fuck, man.
It doesn't even matter,
the whole idea was stupid.
- It was stupid.
- Fuckin' White Lou
gets out of even trying.
Asshole.
- The way White Lou bailed,
he failed fantastically.
- That should be a, you
find yourself in the wrong,
in a WorldStarHipHop video.
- Oh, you don't even want headphones?
- No.
- Acapella?
- Oh, dude.
He almost 8-Mile'd you.
- Oh, you need 'em.
- What's that?
- Or else you get to
hear how out of rhythm your steps are.
- Oh man, I'm out of breath.
Jacob, can you come up
here for a little bit?
Just right here, right here's good.
- Uh-oh.
- Thank you sir.
(all laughing)
- Now he's gonna serve your ass.
- Here we go, this is it.
Black Lou's response to
Jacob in EDM shuffle dancing.
(Dan and Big Jay shouting)
(Black Lou laughs)
- He's about to bust a twerk in your face.
- Oh!
- Hot block!
- Shuffle dancing!
He just did a turkey walk!
Jacob's not impressed.
(Big Jay cheers)
- He hits a slow-mo on him.
- Oh!
Oh, he opened up his chest and
he's wormin' into his heart!
- You're gettin' served!
- Oh, he's taking him out to dinner!
- Table for one, Jacob Battat!
- Oh shit!
(Dan yelling)
- Response!
- Oh fuck!
- Russian! (laughs)
- Oh, immediate kickback!
- Russian kick, Jacob
scrambling around! (yells)
- Oh, somebody call an ambulance,
we're having an interracial seizure!
- Get Steve Harvey in here,
this shits gettin' too street.
Everyone needs, y'all
need to chill, playboy!
- Someone's gotta street it
down, he wants you to get,
oh, he wants you outta the way.
Is there gonna be a flip?
Black Lou's about to flip.
- Now you guys are just breakdancing.
(all yelling)
- Oh shit!
- [DJ Lou] Holy fuck me!
- Hey Lou, great stealing
my move at the end.
(all laughing)
- I think there's only
one way to settle this.
It's now Jacob and Lou's
radio show, we have to leave.
- We're outta here.
- It's now The Bonfire with
Jacob Battat and Louis.
(electric guitar chords)
(fire crackling)